in western China this is Xi'an the
country's ancient Capital it was once
the starting point of the historical
Silk Road a network of trade routes
spread across Central Asia and in this
symbolic location China is seeking to
strengthen connections with its
neighbors
for the first time president Xi Jinping
is hosting the leaders of Kazakhstan
Kyrgyzstan Tajikistan Turkmenistan and
Uzbekistan it would be very important
for
all six countries that they can talk
about you know how they can start
economic recovery and continue the
friendship and their very stable ties
Central Asian countries are seeking to
strengthen trade ties and as Moscow
pours funds into its war in Ukraine and
faces the economic impact of sanctions
analysts say Beijing is an increasingly
appealing partner China can uh play a
more supported role
in in the region and and working with
the region but not at the expense of of
Russia trade between China and Central
Asian Nations hit a record high of 70
billion dollars in 2022 and many
transport infrastructure projects such
as Railways and roads have been built in
the past decade as part of China's
so-called Belton Road initiative the
summit coincides with a meeting of the
leaders of the group of seven developed
economies hosted by Japan China's
growing influence is expected to be one
of the main points of discussion as the
U.S pushes for a more unified approach
to dealing with Beijing
state-funded think tanks say the Xi'an
Summit shows a shift in the world order
these seven developed countries that
dominated current will order and have
the Monopoly power of the current War
economic order are Western Nations while
China and the five Central Asian
countries represent interest and demands
of developing countries
in this week of parallel Summits this is
China's answer to multilateral diplomacy
reframing Global Affairs outside Western
dominance and surrounding itself with
friendly nations in a time of
geopolitical uncertainty
Jessica Washington Al Jazeera Xi'an
China